>>The most pressing issue today is basically
social responsibility.
So we have plenty of people here that are
social entrepreneurs selected
by the Schwab Foundation that try to combine,
to show responsibility
[INAUDIBLE] and business so how can we move
the world, a more
responsibile world?
Because you it can be very romantic by telling
we have to change this
or we have to change that.
What about the climate change what about this?
But at the end of the day, it is the person
who is fighting or
struggling for a new system of sewage or for
clean energy or for
helping women who are mutilated since birth.
These are the basically, the real issues that
nobody discuss.
So let's take our time and do our things,
our mission in life because
our life is our mission, having more social
responsibility in what we
do.
So the basic question is are we doing enough
to transform our life in
our own missions?
Thank you.